all right we have
no sound on YouTube
[Music]
thank you
all right we are opening up the door and
going live I see we're live on YouTube
and
Rumble and Facebook so hello to all of
you out there and hello to all of you in
here in the room here with us at Daily
with Doc zoom.com if you would like to
join us live and you're not already with
us go ahead and do so by going to daily
with Doc Zoom z-o-oom.com
my name is Becca dukes and I am excited
to be here with you wait a minute
where's our special guest going
so you guys may not be able to see all
of the cameras but I can see all the
cameras and I'm glad that I have all of
my co-hosts with me to help keep an eye
on those things also
but hello also to the ksco and k-o-m-y
and our other syndicated radio stations
that are carrying this program and
continuing on sharing the message of
hope hope and being able to take our own
hands into our
are taking our health into our own hands
through nutrition so thank you so much
uh for continuing that Mr Billy and Mr
MZ we greatly appreciate it I know Dr
Wallach loves the fact that we are
continuing to reach that audience as
well
well it's the crow Hostess of dailywick
doc I welcome you this program is meant
for educational purposes only it is not
meant to take the place of your primary
care physician and our products
do not diagnose treat or cure any
diseases the FDA requires us to let you
know this but folks when you give your
body what it needs
intentionally through supplementation
because our food is void of the
nutrients all the nutrients that we need
your body can do some amazing things and
that's what this program has been put
together for is to share that
information
that educates people on the importance
of intentional supplementation and it's
not just cherry picking this and this
for that and that folks every
cell within the body is connected
Dr Wallach who is the doctor that we
host here on daily with Doc he is the
doc that we are talking about he has a
Bachelor's of Science in agriculture he
has a doctorate of veterinarian medicine
he also has three post doctorates in
pathology
and folks a pathologist doesn't just cut
somebody open and do a visual they take
samples of different parts of the body
they look at them under slides they do
analyzes of what minerals
are there within that subject and what
are not and they take all of those data
points like millions of data points he's
been look he's looked at over the years
and he has gone a little bit farther he
has taken what he's learned as a
veterinarian
and has done a correlation
when he did the autopsies on the humans
and found that there is a direct
correlation and another thing that he
found is when something was missing
some of the same diseases were present
some of the same conditions were present
some of the same causes of death were
present because of those nutritional
deficiencies
so with all of his experience and
knowledge and then teaching that because
he could not find something that he felt
solid in recommending
because what he had available to him was
not doing the trick he put a team
together that formulated products that
are the solution at least they were for
me and many of my clients I usually
almost all of my clients that have taken
the products and continue to take the
products
have found solutions to the things that
were keeping them from reaching their
optimal health goals so without further
ado
if you were invited to this program by
somebody specific make sure that you get
back with them and thank them for taking
the time to share this show with you
because folks
there's so many people telling us
that we have to listen to certain people
well have you ever thought about taking
information and
thinking about it
does it make sense
does it make sense to take a chemical
that has 15 serious side effects
for one condition that might be
bothering you a little bit
it didn't for me
and when I did the supplementation I
didn't have to worry about any of those
and Dr Wallach I have you to thank for
that so
thank you thank you thank you Dr Wallach
for all that you have done
how come that did that
hold on hold on we're back
it was one of those things Jerusalem and
I were talking about this before that
you know you try to Spotlight something
and if they unmute or mute or anywhere
in the room it changes the orders of
where people are just love it so here
you are Dr Wallach thank you for joining
me here on daily with Doc welcome I know
you've got some interesting things to
think about
and share with us because you've been
thinking about them so what are your
thoughts today okay and you didn't get
to the point where I went back to school
and became a physician too oh I got
interrupted that's right you went back
that and why did you do that Dr Wallach
why did you go back to school to become
a naturopathic physician and treat
people
okay because when I found the first
non-human case of physical brosis that
one of the
um
monkeys at Yorky's Primary Center
um and found that it wasn't a genetic
disease it was a simple nutritional
efficiency and got it all written up to
present and they fired me because they
said well he must be stiffing glue
everybody knows that scissor process is
a genetic disease
and um when Yorkie's primate Center big
Federal agency is a space program and
everything fires you you're not going to
get a job with anybody else okay some
out there looking for a job and I I went
to you know all these events
and got a job teaching nutrition at the
nature Havoc College up in Portland
Oregon and I said why don't I just get
the degree and become an HVAC doctor at
the same time I'm teaching nutrition I
can see what credit I can get for all my
previous courses and everything and take
whatever courses are missing and become
an HIV doctor which I did and I
graduated in let's see here
1982 1982 became a naturally doctor it
was very obvious you know my little
squeaky voice going up and down the
block I'd see three or four patients a
week or something like that that wasn't
working so I had to find a way to get
the information now says I have to build
an army this is going to require an army
to pull this off here because it's so
dramatically different than everything
everybody else is doing
and
so that's when I went and learned about
home-based businesses and this and the
other and they said I'm going to build
an army just like they do in small
countries when there's a war going on
they knock on doors and say okay come on
we need you to help fight down me and so
that's how I started doing this and so
I'm very very proud of that thing that
in the beginning if you listen to my
original
CDs dead doctors online said we have to
farm an army and get this information
out there throughout the world and this
has been working very very well now
The Beat Goes On okay The Beat Goes On
it's a never-ending story as they say
and
one of the
um wonderful stories again has to do
with uh my book uh the wallet Revolution
and in the Warlock Revolution you notice
that Pat Boone okay the famous singer
and actor uh wrote the forward okay
and Danny Glover a great comedian and
actor
um did the what they called the
afterward which is the last chapter
chapter both of them telling their
stories
um Danny Glover had seizures and all
that kind of stuff and we were able to
get rid of all that and with the healthy
brain and heart pack
and then
um when it came to
um
see here
Pat Boone guess what he had arthritis
and he was going to get you know double
knee replacement he was gonna you know
they're talking about amputating legs
and all this kind of stuff and somebody
I don't know who it was but whoever it
is I have to thank him
um they they and I think I know who it
is I think it was probably
um attorney
okay but anyway went to a pat Boone's
ahead we can help you we put them on the
same program that we put a guy by the
name of Theo ratliffon we're gonna we're
coming out with his story here pretty
quick because it says like the 20 20th
plus anniversary he just turned 50 years
old and he had bone bone arthritis in
his knees yeah he's only 24 years old
Carl was slipping off his hips he
fractured his shooting arm wrist on his
right arm they took away his 35 million
dollar contract and kicked him out and
said you know there's nothing we can do
you're you're such a sicko here we can't
have you on the team because we can
never depend on you to always be there
can't pay that much money and so uh his
Pastor brought him to me we came up with
the healthy Bone and Joint pack for him
which is our Healthy Start pack and we
had to come up with our glucajel which
is our first collagen product which we
added to it and so it became the healthy
Bone and Joint pack
and then three months later we came out
with our rebounder sports drink with 100
nutrients in it instead of like Red Bull
was only one nutrient in it and it's one
of those things where all these things
were kind of taking place and we rebuilt
um we rebuilt a Theo in uh six months
and he went back he got he played for 11
years and he was a Top Shot blocker for
many many years he was also one of the
top scorers for many many years and we
just loved to tell his story okay
because it's such a beautiful story well
well guess what
Pat Boone saw that story
and so our our people started telling
him about it and he took our program and
we rebuilt his knees and his hips and
all that kind of stuff and he's doing
fine and that was many years ago now and
of course
um he said you know if there's anything
we can ever do for you let us know and
of course he wrote the forward to this
book he wrote the forward to the book he
tells his story in here about his
arthritis and everything like that what
we did for him beautiful story now the
story gets better because now he's just
releasing a new movie
um uh he was born like four years before
me almost the same date
okay
so yeah
um
I think it was eight years before you
he's
Oh no you're right
you're right you guys are right at five
five years apart yep
and um uh anyway he he was able to heal
his arthritis in his knees and his hips
and anybody's else we didn't know all
the story but that's what we knew and
now he's playing the part of a retired
uh golf pro senior golf pro growing
around and witnessing the good Lord to
all these athletes and uh visitors who
come to watch the golf games and and so
forth
so we're very very proud of our
relationship with Pat Boone we cannot
thank him enough for writing the phone
number to the book I mean he did has
everything he does such a great job and
Rebecca went through and picked out a
lot of his music um the stuff that I had
listened to for over 50 years and put
them all on one uh disc or tape or
whatever you call it and I get to listen
to that of two or three days out of the
week I just you know have a little bit
of time if I'm doing paperwork or doing
something else or maybe eating a meal
I'm listening to Pat Boone singing all
his his songs okay so he cannot thank
Pat Boone enough now the same thing on a
lesser scale but on the same issue okay
is
um again our buddy
Danny Glover okay
he had all his seizures and so forth we
got rid of those and so he wrote the
afterward the last chapter of the book
so that's why these two guys wrote the
last chapter and the forward okay we
cannot thank him enough for sharing
their stories
and telling how well the youngee
programs and products work for them
and we're going to promote
um uh Pat Boone's movie like crazy I
haven't seen it yet but we're going to
get a copy real quick here uh Becca says
she's going to work on that today we're
going to get a copy of that movie and uh
we're gonna watch it and we're gonna
show it and um
anything that Pat Boone does is
phenomenal so I'm sure it's going to be
a great a great movie it's already being
released it's not like they're making it
now it's already been made and so it's
being released as we speak and so I'm so
very very excited about this and I again
I cannot thank
um Pat Boone enough
and for
um everything he does for Humanity
everything he does for this great
country everything he does for the world
and we're just so so proud to be
or have an association with him and have
a history with him okay Pat Boone and
Danny Glover two great guys and but
right now at the top of the at the top
of the lantern is Pat Boone because his
new movie is being released as we speak
and I'm sure it'll be a great one just
like all his movies
so
um with that said I'll remind everybody
and of course Rebecca's working as a
party to get this
um
uh podcast out on our interview we did
uh with um Theo okay he just turned 50
and
um it has I don't know I think three
nice looking young boys sons and um it's
one of those things where
he's he's a good family man uh he made a
lot of money and he bought some training
facilities in his home state and he
makes it open for free to kids in school
who want to learn skills and things
first things they want to do in the
future
um learn skills so they can pass courses
and all this kind of stuff and so he's
putting a lot of that money back into
the community to make sure his community
moves forward with him I mean again a
great beautiful part of the story
so those are
um you know we have a lot of famous
people I'm going to start making a list
of all the famous people we have helped
with their health issues and you know
movie stars
um athletes of all kinds
um billionaires
um race car drivers
um great teachers professors researchers
and we have some new ones coming on we
have some new ones coming on I can't
tell you their names yet because they're
just now coming out of the woodwork and
they've been spending months and weeks
working on their projects and they're
saying okay we're done we're ready to go
and so we're kind of excited about that
but we can't quite tell you yet what it
is but there's so many new things
happening here
The Beat Goes On
and so
um just remember it all comes down to
the basics
you cannot get everything you need from
your food
your food because plants do not make
minerals and two-thirds of the essential
nutrients are minerals nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform
blanket around the coast of the earth
they occur in veins like gold and silver
the only way to guarantee you're going
to get all the nutrition you need is to
supplement now people say well what did
people do a long time ago well they
supplemented they supplemented with wood
ashes okay wood ashes and coal ashes or
are a source of minerals for thousands
and thousands of years they put the wood
ashes of coal ashes into the gardens and
the vegetables would suck up the
minerals and again all the vegetables
all over the place didn't have the same
amount of minerals okay so they had
someone had three minerals some had five
minerals some had 20 minerals but that's
where they would get people we're
getting their minerals and then when we
went to electricity at three o'clock in
the afternoon Monday September 4th 1882
and Tylenol pulled that switch
within 18 years by 1900 guess what we
had a problem no more wood ashes no more
coal ashes no more minerals they even
had dams blocking the floods so he
didn't have bottom land anymore and
that's why we have all these diseases
now and the only way you can make up for
that difference
okay without burning down a forest area
here adding wood ashes is to supplement
and that's why people need what we do
don't forget our season it's all from
Australia New Zealand don't forget
there's our salts from the
um let's see here the Himalayan
Mountains okay
it's one of the things where the hunzas
their life expectancy is 120.
they're not part of the they're not part
of the developed World their life
expectancy is 120 many lives be 130 140
150. that's because of the minerals that
are coming out of the volcanoes
goes back to the old days you know the
biblical days and pre-biblical days
we're talking about the land flowing
with milk and honey being a farmer I
said oh where were they getting all the
milk back then there was no talk about
milk in the Garden of Eden there's no
talk about dairy cows and and dairy
goats in the Garden of Eden where was
all that milk and honey stuff coming
from
well they're talking about streams that
look like milk
because the streams as they were melting
up in the mountains were grabbing clay
and minerals from Limestone everything
so the suspended very small mineral
particles made that water look like milk
White
and so is this white colored stream
water coming down the mountains they're
saying that this was land flowing with
milk and honey it wasn't cow's milk or
goat's milk it was mineral milk that's
why Methuselah lived to be 969.
okay and so I'm very very excited about
this and we of course have access the
information and even better than that we
have access to the stuff
so I urge you to Avail yourself of
everything we know that you need
you you pay wholesale prices you get on
auto ship I will pay the shipping
and if you do this as a home-based
business you get tremendous tax breaks
okay you get back thousands of dollars
at the end of the year if you run your
business okay out of your home
you don't have to pay another Mortgage
in a shopping mall run it out of your
home
and you get great tax breaks 25 percent
of your space in your home 25 deduction
off of your taxes for your your mortgage
your rent and your your utilities and
and so forth okay so this is a great
thing and of course
when you retire and or die guess what
your youngeity business goes to your
family or church or whoever you want to
leave it to you work for a big
Corporation when you retire die does
that job you did for them making them
millions of dollars in over 20 years
when you die or retire does your family
get that job you held no
I don't say quit that job keep that job
but start building your young Duty
business so you have something you leave
for your family
okay with that said back to you Becca
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
so folks
there's a lot of great things going on
and it doesn't take being famous to make
a difference in your communities
we as individuals
have the
empowerment the duty whatever it takes
whatever words you want to fill in there
if you're in if you're here with us in
the chat go ahead what would be a good
word that I could use for that put it in
the chat
um but it's having that ability to be
able to take information and share it
with others
is incredible
especially those phone calls that you
get or those texts that you get
throughout the day and night
that say thank you
or this just happened it hasn't happened
in forever or my blood pressure is now
normal I mean there's so many different
things where nutrition
that's all it took
the medical establishment Dr Wallach has
made it so complicated at least they
make it sound like it's complicated and
in all actuality it's not it's very
simple you do have to be purposeful you
do have to be intentional
but
you eat so why not just make sure that
you're eating the things that are
feeding the body
and not destroying the body
and I mean Pat Boone is a great example
he still sings Dr Wallach
there's a lot of
singers artists
that are in their 30s and 40s that can't
anymore because their larynx is crushing
or damaged or they don't have the lung
capacity because of
lung issues
we're looking at nutritional
deficiencies that are causing yeah or
frontal temporal display uh dementia
all of these things
can be
lessened as far as occurrence if not
completely removed from your history
your future
both history and Future
when taken the nutrients that are giving
the body what it needs but most
importantly in an absorbable format
because not all supplements are created
equal
I learned that Dr Wallach it cost a lot
of money to learn that lesson and I
threw a lot of things out when I
switched over to you
and things worked
it's like felt the difference within
days
and and that's something that I get also
in those texts so you know it's really
amazing
how me
I mean I was a farm girl Dr Wallach
in a small town where the population
grew around it and then I moved to an
even smaller town that was a ghost town
population five my family
um
but I still built a business
and I love it and now I'm here in San
Diego and I love conveniences
so Focus you can do it as well if you
have always had a passion and a heart to
help people why not help them through
their health as well helping them find a
better health Journey
and it's okay to
share something and profit
every time you buy something you're
profiting somebody else
every time you refer somebody
to a store or a product you're making
somebody else money
it's okay for us to help pay our own
bills
by referring somebody to a product that
we know with 100 percent certainty
will help
so get back with the person that shared
this program with you and say hey let me
hear about this business
how can I make this a business around
what I'm already doing
and work into something that's going to
be even greater like Dr Wallach said I
mean I have 401ks that you know my
family will continue collect on but
they're nothing like what my business is
creating
and what I'm able to leave to them
so that's something that as a single I
was a teenage mom doc never dreamed I'd
be able to do this for my kids but I'm
doing it
and
I I love it so
and I love the fact that I have other
people that believed in me
because I knew I was smart I knew I had
skills just believed in me enough to
give me the opportunity to use those to
help the community as a whole so I thank
you Dr Wallach I thank you youngevity I
think the other leaders within
youngevity for allowing me to be here
and share this program and the other
coaches for showing up and bringing
their clients and customers and
potential and future coaches
so that they also can fill the community
and the love and the togetherness of
this family
well Dr Wallach we have hands that are
uh
um and I have some questions here in the
chat and one is a carryover from
yesterday so yesterday Dr wellick
um we had a woman who
was in final stage renal failure and I
found out that the damage to her kidneys
was because of a prescription so like
what I mentioned before why take
something for one thing when it's
causing damage in 12 other locations of
the body this woman has experienced it
my heart goes out to her
but
she's she's been able to go or improve
kidney function to stage three but it's
still
chronic kidney disease Dr Wallach
can the kidneys be repaired or do we
just support them to function the best
that they possibly can at this moment
okay well thank you okay for all the
kind history and story uh okay and your
beautiful story and
um
when it comes to
repairing the kidneys is actually quite
simple
we take people that haven't urinated in
10 years now you think about that they
haven't urinated in 10 years they're on
dialysis six days a week they spend
their life in the dialysis clinics okay
we get them on get them off all the bad
foods to stop all the inflammation to
the arteries and the tubes and the
kidneys and the glomeruli the filtering
units and all kinds I'll get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no glutens no
wheat nobody Ryan oats no sugar no
carbonate or drinks even the carbonated
water needs to go and then per 100
pounds of body weight we get them on one
healthy brand and heart pack a month it
has 215 nutrients including the 90 that
everybody agrees upon 16 minerals 16
vitamins 12 measures Three fatty acids
but I like the big hammer in these cases
okay
um
so per 100 pounds of body weight one
Health brand hard pack per month
and then I want her to have
um two bottles a month per hundred
pounds of body weight of the ultimate
daily classic tablets that's three words
ultimate daily classic talents ultimate
daily classic tablets take three
um twice a day okay minimum I do that
and I only weigh 142 pounds but if
somebody has these kidney issues I'd
have them take three three times a day
the ultimate daily classic tablets
and within two weeks time
now remember they hadn't urinated in 10
years in two weeks time they're
urinating so they dropped the they
dropped the dialysis down from six days
a week down to three days a week and two
more weeks are totally off of dialysis
because her urine is perfect their
kidneys are functioning properly the
blood pressure has come down into the
normal range because usually when you
have a kidney issue the blood pressure
is up okay and so don't cold turkey off
the blood pressure medication with a
starter program but as the blood
pressure drops you can slowly reduce
medication based on the numbers okay
and so I always say give us 90 days but
usually within two to four weeks you're
going to see some miraculous benefits
okay and so give us 90 days but then
people say well how long do I have to
stay on these nutrients well as long as
you want to live
how long do you put all in your car how
long do you put gasoline in your car how
long do you put air in your tires okay
how long do you keep one eye on that red
warning light in your dashboard of your
car same thing is true for us
um well doesn't oxygen cause rusting of
iron
yes
but iron doesn't have a circulatory
system okay doesn't have things that
neutralize all those bad things that
oxygen can do
you require oxygen
okay every second of every day now
here's a here's a scary thing
your heart beats normally somewhere
between 65 and 80 times
a minute
unless you're exercising
because when I'm doing an intense
intense exercise Dr Wallach I get up to
145.
yeah but that's at the peak of the
exercise okay I'm talking about just
sitting watching TV or resting okay
at rest or sleeping okay so normally so
let's say your range of of your your
heart rate is going to be somewhere
between 70 and 120 depending on what's
going on
and
then
[Music]
um
now just per minute
actually you threw away one of my papers
where I had calculated
[Laughter]
I did not throw it away
isn't a pile somewhere okay I I'll do it
again I calculated how many times your
heart beats if you die
at say 80 years old it was like
000 years or something like that your
heart beats okay 21 000 years
because per minute
per minute
your heart beats 60 to 80 times a minute
okay and so it beats when you're asleep
it beats when you're exercising it beats
when you're eating it beats when you're
driving it beats you know when you're at
work it never stops you don't want it to
stop because then you die okay now you
think about that do you think we need to
pay attention to what's going on with
our heart well yeah okay and that's why
we came out with a Hildebrand and heart
pack because your heart is one of the
key
um
pieces of Machinery your body requires
to live a long Health life okay and so
when you think about just think of how
many times your heart beats in a 24-hour
period in an hour if your heart's
beating eight times a minute okay
multiply that times 60. do some quick
math there see see how many times that
beats in an hour well 80 times 60 that's
what 4 800 or yeah four thousand eight
hundred times beats per minute okay so
your heart beats four thousand eight
hundred times an hour
per hour yes per hour now do you think
your heart's worth taken care of duh
okay you can't just say well I'm eating
well
I I just yeah I just really get very
upset with doctors when they say stuff
like that oh don't don't worry about
that don't take any advantage don't
waste your money on that just eat well
gears you need
um this is um
that's why there's no doctors that live
to be a hundred
the average lifespan the medical doctor
in the emergency room in America they
should be living in the top is 58.7
as reported in the medical journals I
didn't make that up it was 58.7
uh there's hardly a testimony to what
they know or do
okay it's probably because they don't
give their heart any nutrients it's
probably just living on
colas
and um
hot dogs and
waffles for breakfast or oatmeal for
breakfast because and Mountain Dew
doctor what
it's chips and Mountain Dew well there
you go chips and Mountain Dew that's
what that's what what doctors eat okay
is potato chips and Mountain Dew okay
fried foods not all of them there are
some Dr Wallach that are a little more
mindful they do realize that they need
to stay away from that stuff
and they're eating oatmeal
the answer to your question in a year if
you are beating your heart is beating
which is does more than just be make a
sound it's pumping blood through the
body so that you have good circulation
throughout the body
fingertips don't die
but at 80 beats per minute in a year Dr
Wallach that is 2 billion
522 million eight hundred and eighty
thousand beats for the year how many
billion
2.5 billion if you want to round it wow
I get tired just listening to that
figure
that's that's a lot yeah well yeah I
have important
I don't think I don't think many people
have thought about that how many times
my heart beat
you know
a minute an hour
a year now that was just a year right
but yeah that's in a year that's not a
lifetime two billion times a year
okay 10 years that's 20 billion times
and you're not going to treat your heart
right
my exercise
if you are you supplementing no well no
I do supplement I take vitamin C every
day well you're only 89 nutrients short
yeah
oh goodness Dr Wallach let's go to the
to a hand that we have here with us and
um Don I know we didn't get to your
question yesterday could you raise your
hand please so we can get to you today
and the first hand that we're going to
go to Dr Wallach is Rosemary hello
Rosemary welcome to daily with Doc
hello thank you for taking my call I
have a client Dr Wallach that is getting
a frozen shoulder
and he won't exercise so is there
anything I could tell him that he might
be able to take that would help with
that
do you have any idea how much he weighs
about 170 175 about six foot okay do you
know how old he is
he's roughly my age 77 78. okay
all right well the odds are there's
other issues going on if he's got
something going on with his shoulder he
may have a little blood pressure issues
he may have some blood sugar problems
either for pre-diabetes or maybe even
not reactive hemoglycemia he may have
some joint problems he may have some
bowel problems you know he may have
irritable bowel syndrome uh he may have
asthma you know who he knows what also
he's got skin problems who knows what
he's got right he has had prostate
surgery okay
well that translates to a doctor had a
kid in college and tuition was due
they opted not to do the chemo though
okay
so
you need to get rid of all the bad foods
need to get a hold of that book uh Dr
wants cooking without the bad foods 300
pages of safe recipes safe cooking
methods and it has a good food bad food
list Dr walks cooking without the bad
foods then he needs to take two healthy
brain and heart pasture months photos
are saying twice a day and he's two
miles a month the MSM so we take three
brackets three lunch at dinner time
they're going to support and promote
major pair of cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrate bone makes your bone
itself including the shoulder okay
needs to take the collagen peptides take
a scuba this morning drinks with the
evening drink I also want him to take
our ultimate daily classic tablets take
three of those twice a day they'll
support healthy blood pressure but also
I wanted to support healthy blood flow
into his bones into the bone marrow
cavities including his shoulders and
skull and hips and knees and vertebrae
and so forth
and so let's go there and um when the
history of the prostate issue we need a
little you know more information uh
before we suggest any other nutrients
but let's start there and um this as far
as the shoulder if it's a simple
osteoporosis thing or simple arthritis
thing degenerative arthritis and and
it's not arthritis is not an aging thing
you can have all this arthritis when
you're a newborn baby okay
and it has to do with the
nutrients that the mother was or was not
getting
so uh let's go that direction and
um you know give us any time he gets
looked at by a doctor
or you know even just in two weeks time
let us know was he seeing any benefit
okay is he getting if he has really
disruptive pain where he's really
uncomfortable and just causing him to be
in a dangerous situation and driving or
at work we do have the CM cream okay
this will give him apply that to his
shoulder maybe once every three or four
hours okay and then we also have soothe
which is from our hempf exhibition
that'll give you a pain relief for oh
anywhere from four to six hours okay and
so if you're going to be at home you can
use a CM cream you're going to be out
and about I would use the
um soothe from our hemp FX and so we you
know those two things are available
and it's one of those things where
we have programs to take care of these
issues including
shoulders when people complain about
their shoulders as that's their major
complaint
okay but there's I guarantee there's all
this other stuff going on there yeah
Beyond prescription drugs and say well
yeah I don't have this I don't have that
anymore because my doctor gave me a
prescription for this but but the
prescriptions don't solve the problem
they just relieve the symptoms
well the real quick thank you I was
having trouble going up and down stairs
and that's getting much better
so I've done a lot of things for me okay
listen well thank you for sharing the
story did you take the healthy Bone and
Joint pack or the healthy brain and
heartbeat what did you take
um no but I did take everything you told
me to take okay
I remember what you told her to take Dr
Wallach okay
and it's the osteoporosis of the skull
protocol with the brain and heart pack
and the MSM and the collagen and the
ultimate daily classic and I think
vitamin D3 was also in there possibly
yeah well money's an issue so I didn't
take all of it but it's still getting
better
could have been all could have been
perfect by now but I didn't get didn't
have the money for that well that's an
issue you have to deal with and so you
know you do the basics and then you know
you just as things get better you do
your add-on but you'll save a lot of
money by staying away from the bad foods
bad foods I have I have okay good
get rid of those bad foods you will save
a lot of money thank you very much well
thank you for sharing
thank you Rosemary
thank you
Dr Wallach you know I was
very limited on funds when I started on
this program and I started feeling the
difference without doing your full
protocol not saying that people should
not go for the full protocol but if
finances are
something to consider
get started on at least the foundation
of the 90 essential nutrients
it'll make a world of difference and
you'll save money by getting rid of the
bad food so you can buy the other stuff
well you're saving money by getting rid
of the bad foods so you can buy the
additional nutrients but even that
little bit doctor while like allowed me
to drop some of my Pharmaceuticals that
were costing a lot of money that then
allowed me to be able to get what I
really needed
and Achieve almost Optimal Health so
and it's still a work in progress I love
the fact that it's it's not an
okay that's it that's as good as you're
gonna get
things just keep getting get better
because we're creating cells each and
every moment of the day
so make sure that your body has the
nutrients that it needs so that it can
create healthier and healthier cells
we have a comment here oh goodness we
need to hurry so Irene wants to know
is this normal blood pressure for a male
that is 76 175 pounds and six foot this
morning his blood pressure this is her
husband was 88 over 44. that sounds a
little bit low
yeah I mean there'd be people killed her
blood pressure like this I mean you know
their blood pressure is run 150 over 90
150 over 100 and this was medication
okay and so 88 88 over
um 44 44 over 44. oh my gosh 88 over 44.
I've had as low as 51 and felt great yes
yeah my top number is 65 I think
but then I take a lot of stuff
yeah so
um so definitely something to keep an
eye
uh on I would say
yeah especially if you're on
Pharmaceuticals and you start taking a
program like ours where you've got
quality supplementation where the body
is absorbing
and then the cells are getting healthier
and healthier absorbing more work with
your primary care physician to make
adjustments to your Pharmaceuticals
because
you may not even need them anymore but
we do recommend
what you want to do is you say you know
I don't need to come to you anymore
because you know I'm healing myself but
what I will do doc tell the doctor doc
what I will do is I'll sell you what I'm
taking for wholesale prices so you can
help yourself
you'll pay wholesale prices you get on
auto ship I will pay the shipping there
you go perfect that
response all right Dr Wallach let's go
to Phyllis Phyllis I know you have a
question for a client
yes I sure do Dr Wallach and this is for
Kathy in Iowa and she is 5'8 200 pounds
and she has had chronically swollen
eyelids since she was a child also
chronic sinus issues I actually have a
picture I will share my screen and show
you in just a moment how that looks
uh her only other health issues she had
a heart attack years ago she is on two
high blood pressure medications the
swelling did get worse a few months back
in November she's seen several doctors
and she said she's been treated for
infection and irritation nothing has
helped so I will go ahead and share my
screen and show you her picture
and um I know it's a little hard to see
but it's basically her upper lid you
almost can't see her lid up to her
eyebrows you know she's too far away
from the screen yeah I can see with her
right eye yeah
at least on my screen is her right eye
okay all right she could have
osteoporosis to the skull which squeezes
the
the 12 pairs of cranial nerves okay she
could have all kinds of stuff going on
there so the station weighs 200 pounds
she's five foot
five foot eight five foot eight okay for
a girl who's five foot eight uh I'd have
her weigh maybe 160 maybe so she's with
30 40 pounds overweight I'd have her
take one meal a day or keto Shake okay
it's a meal replacer it's not to add to
a meal comes in Strawberry or chocolate
uh one meal a day doesn't hit me the
same meal
I never take two healthy branded heart
Parish a month for those I think twice a
day and have her take two bottles a
month of the MSM so you can take three
your breakfast sweet lunch or dinner
time I also wanted to have the ultimate
daily classic tablets at three words
only with daily classical take three of
those twice a day there's two miles a
month as for her high blood pressure
don't cold turkey off the medication but
as the blood pressure drops you slowly
uh
um reduce the medication and then
because she has this had had a heart
attack it could be osteoporosis of the
skull squeezing the tense cranial nerve
which causes atrial fibrillation uh
hyper activity of the heart okay uh also
um a fast heart rate tachycardia slow
heart rate bradycardia and doctors
misinterpret that is a heart issue but
it's the skull squeezing the 10th
cranial nerve causing all those issues
in the heart but the Habit pressure is
very easy to get rid of okay with all
the stuff we just talked about and
she'll lose a half a pound of two pounds
a day with that one keto Shake uh per me
uh per day or is it
per meal per day okay yeah per day yeah
well I should mention too she uh mostly
is not eating the bad foods but she is
not off the gluten wheat barley Ryan
oats or buckwheat yeah if he's eating
one meal a week with one with those
it's just gonna take a little bit longer
for them to kill her but if she's eating
it once a day she's going to be in big
trouble so she needs to get a hold of
that book doctor always cooking without
the bad foods 300 pages of safe recipes
and safe cooking methods and it has a
good food bad food list printed in there
okay Dr likes cooking without the bad
foods and
but also let's see here
um
I would also throw in our objective
throw interock YouTube
three of those twice a day this is a
moderate size bottle so I we can
probably go through two bottles a month
okay to pull that off
okay the occupative
and I really like the adjective it makes
a big big difference okay so do give us
a call uh every couple of weeks let us
know how she's doing because everything
she has here we can improve at the very
least
and we you know need some more
information if she is it's lab work want
to know what her blood pressure is when
her blood sugar is does she get how many
times does she wake up at night a year
and eight once three times five times
ten times we need to know that
information
okay thank you so much well you're very
welcome okay we got one more time I
think for one more quick one here Becca
okay
John
can you hear me now yeah
okay good so
Don I don't think we answered all of
your questions from yesterday you want
to go ahead and unmute yourself and go
ahead and let's finish up with
questions can you hear me yes sir okay
thank you for taking my call
um I'm a new to uh pinky Tangerine here
for the last few months but uh uh I've
been taking lemon juice with my orange
juice in the morning the concentrated or
lemon juice uh is um it seems to make me
feel better is it okay taking like
concentrated lemon juice okay I'll stop
there for a minute how old are you oh
I'm sorry I'm 75. uh about 194
uh 510 take a little blood pressure
medication
um and cholesterol medication
um fairly healthy my numbers are pretty
good
um nothing are you pre-diabetic do you
have any blood sugar problems no no I'm
uh I get a 5.6 5.7 A1C oh good how many
times you wake up at night to urinate
once three times five three or three
sometimes four I feel that pressure at
night uh that's another thing I wanted
to talk to you about what's up well here
we go you have osteoporosis in the skull
squeezing the spinal cord the spinal
cord is telling your urinary bladder to
urinate yes okay that's what's going on
there you may have other symptoms of
osteoporosis skull has your voice
changed you know people say look you got
a cold or something your voice has
changed you know your voice may change
so you lose your sense of taste uh can
you lift your hands above your head uh
yes or no do you ever see her oh good do
you have receding gums
no do you have any tinnitus any ringing
in the ears no okay do you have any
balance problems or dizziness no okay
I'm a runner and Slimmer and biker I do
a lot of exercise pretty active I still
work
and yeah exercise is extremely dangerous
because when you sweat it sweat just
water
sure no it's not sweat is a soup that
contains all your minerals in it oh sure
you need to lick your arm when you sweat
and see how much salt is in your sweat
and if you're just drinking water after
you do all this exercise you're
rehydrating but over time you're slowly
reducing all your mineral reserves your
body and you're in trouble
so instead of drinking orange juice and
lemon juice together I would put in the
rebound
replace that drink was rebound our
rebound has 100 nutrients in it lemon
juice and orange juice may only have
three nutrients in it a lot of sugar
taking the powder
um tanky Tangerine was
water of course and mix it that's fine
that's fine but you also need we do have
the powder in the rebound okay I'll get
it 100 nutrients in here 75 minerals
okay and I take two servings a day of
the rebound okay we have the cancer with
36 servings we have the boxes of the six
was 36 we have the cans there's 12 ounce
cans uh there's 12 in a case but the
cans are carbonated so you need to pop
them two or three of them at night
before I go to bed and put them in the
refrigerator they'll be flat in the
morning all the you know the bubbly
would be gone okay I only weigh 142 but
I drink one at breakfast and I will have
one half of one at noon and then the
other half of the second one I'll kind
of dribble out through the afternoon so
I'm energizing myself to deal with all
the stuff we got to do and so forth okay
but um lemon juice and orange juice was
great you know a long time ago when you
had wood ashes you're getting minerals
in your food
from wood ashes in your garden and wood
ashes in your food but once we went to
electricity
you're not getting enough minerals from
orange juice and and oh I understand
okay okay so you must supplement uh
plants do not make minerals no matter
how well you eat I don't care uh
I don't care you know how many oranges
uh are lemons are
um let's see here our limes you eat you
might get some vitamin C and some sugar
but you don't know what else you're
getting okay that's why they call the
British limeys because they used to
drink so much limes or eat so much limes
to get rid of scurvy
there's a okay they didn't know what it
was and and the limes it got really
scurvy but there was something in those
limes all the British began to eat limes
that's why we call them limeys
all right thank you Don I'm glad we were
able to get that answered for you and Dr
Wallach I know you have to go bye-bye so
thank you so much again for joining us
here on daily with Doc if I could get my
co-hosts up with me that would be
wonderful co-host this is today
um except for out on
on YouTube so sport it sportus
um is doing a great job out there
providing information and support for us
um in YouTube land so
thank you again everybody I hope that
this information
this moment of Education
has empowered you to be able to
go out and reach somebody be a light of
Hope in their life in giving them
options that they're not going to hear
anywhere else so invite them here invite
them to daily withdoc.com get signed up
for our newsletter you will get an
invitation to the program we send out
once a month the week previously the
link to
the program
and a description of the program so you
save those in a special little folder
and then folks if you're doing the
coaching program all you have to do is
search your email for a certain
condition
those emails will come up and point you
directly to
the program that was shared here on
daily with Doc about what is
in of Interest or concern to you and
those you love I just want to thank my
co-hosts Marilyn pazara Speer and
Phyllis Anderson and Ruth Ellen Sanchez
for being on here with me
dedicating and donating their time to
serve a greater good folks we're here
for the greater good we
support a lot of different people
a lot of people that are within our
individual immediate organization and
the Health Community as a whole
so get back with a person that shared
this program with you tell them thank
you ask them where they would send you
to get the products that are mentioned
that would be best for you and if
there's nobody to think go to daily
withdoc.com if you would like to speak
with a health coach and you have never
spoken with anybody about any of the
youngevity products or
Dr Wallach they've not somebody hasn't
shared Dr Wallach with you then please
feel free to use that contact us on the
website that will send us an email
letting us know that you are interested
in getting with a certified holistic
health coach to help you pick the
products that would be a best fit for
you
we do have a call team also standing by
855-949-3377 so if you would like to
speak with somebody on the phone and
you've never spoken with anybody about
the products or Dr Wallach feel free to
call that number as well again that's
855-949-3377 that is the daily with Doc
call team so everybody have a wonderful
and horrific weekend be empowered
to reclaim your health and have a
brighter future with less pain bye for
now
record
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign